so let's say you open the borders to
your country and let in seven million
new people who had no connection to
America whatsoever didn't speak the
language weren't from here here
illegally but you did that that would
make the society less cohesive than ever
and then you so much managed the economy
that was on the way into recession
that's the last moment you would want to
make Americans hate each other on the
basis of race because if you did that
the whole thing could just blow up like
that's too crazy and Reckless but that's
exactly what the
current Administration Joe Biden's
Administration is doing here's Joe Biden
innocent men women children hung by
noose from trees bodies burned drowned
castrated lens for simply being black
nothing more hard to believe but that's
what was done and some people still want
to do that
some people still want to do that who
are those people exactly Vince Everett
Ellison is producer of will you go to
hell for me an amazing documentary he's
made that we showed you earlier he joins
us today Vince thanks so much for coming
on some people still want to do that who
is the president talking about who are
these would-be lynchers
he's probably talking about Democrats
because they were the ones doing it
before uh when we look back over history
the Democratic party were the ones doing
Jim Crow that was lynching and killing
and castrating black men and they're
still doing it now
um you're going to any inner city in
America the Democrats run it I mean it's
a freak Show man you got Lori Lightfoot
and uh Pete booty judge and that crazy
Sam Brinkmann guy a Britain guy that was
running around putting women's clothes
on I mean that's just who they are uh
it's it's it's an insane asylum now
that's taken over the Democratic party
and we have to just start calling it
exactly what it is
the Democratic party Heaven is an
American hell
it is no doubt you go to any big city
and you see dysfunction you've seen that
they released this hip-hop culture and
they've destroyed every institution that
protected the children from these bad
things and now the n-word the b word the
W word is being sung by these artists
and they're elevated they go to the
White House in the Super Bowl now so how
can these young men and young women not
believe that they're not that so you got
Lori Lightfoot you got Joe Biden running
for re-election they should be
apologizing forever been in office
they're the worst president and the
worst mayor in history
Lori Lightfoot has presided over a
dystopia every weekend we look at how
many children are dying in Chicago
um we look at what Joe Biden has done I
mean what are they going to run on uh we
want to sexually groom your children
uh we want to have a grown men go to the
bathroom with your daughters uh we're
going to uh keep your children locked in
fell in schools we want to let fentanyl
come across the border that's what
that's the only thing they can run on so
what do what do they say
they hate you because you're black
and we can protect you
well look C.S Lewis said hell is a
choice
and it is
but you can unchoose it they talk about
systemic racism and and uh institutional
racism well if it is an Institutional
racism they are the ones that provided
because they run all the institutions in
the black community
they run the schools they run the
churches they destroyed them all
yeah it's institutional racism caused by
them
they talk about white privilege well let
me tell you something it is privileged
to be white and it's also a privilege to
be black
it's it's a privilege of me to live in
America it's a privilege to me to be a
Christian and for the Christians in the
ghetto let me tell y'all you can you can
come above this you're the name of Jesus
Christ you're a Son of God nobody can
oppress you nobody is better than you
there's no racism that can hold you down
stand up look at these people in the eye
and tell them who you are you are an
American you're strong you're resilient
and you'll get through this
amen ignore what they say watch what
they do Vince Everett Ellison always
there you go to Common Sense appreciate
his documentary is out this week it was
great
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight